- Welcome to The Kelly
Clarkson Show everybody.
(audience audience cheering and clapping)
Like she said, give it
up in my band, y'all.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Dolly] That's a good
band you got there, Kelly.
- They're an amazing band
that can play literally any genre you ask,
and so can you.
So give it up for Dolly Parton, y'all.
The one and only.
Give it up for her
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Thank you for
singing that with me.
- Well, I have been so looking
forward to doing the show
and just singing with you, period
is just a very exciting thing.
So thank you
for doing that with me.
- Absolutely.
Yeah.
We got to do
the re-imagined version nine to five
but we haven't done it live yet.
So we got to mix it in there a little bit.
So I was very excited.
- Oh, I know we did that
for a documentary call.
- Yes.
- Still working nine to five.
- Yeah.
- So there's a version.
- So good.
- So maybe sometime
you'll get a chance to hear that.
We can do it all one day.
- Yeah, still relevant.
Yeah, yeah.
Is it true that you invited
women at your record label
to be in the video?
I thought that was so cool.
- I did!
when I did nine to five.
Back 40 what?
Two years ago or so.
I just watched it on
the set and I played my.
(nails clicking)
My nails.
(audience cheers)
- I can't, look, these
are single mama nails.
- I know.
Well, these are acrylics.
- These are gross.
- You gotta have falsies.
(laughing)
Anyway, I was playing my acrylic nails
and I watched all the
things going on on the set
and so I just watched all the girls
doing whatever they did and
it was about working women.
- Yeah.
- So when I wrote the song,
got ready to record it.
I thought how cool would it
be to invite all the women?
- Yeah.
- That worked in the offices
and all the people on the
set and all the girls.
- You keep it real.
- Yeah.
So they all sang on it
and they got credit.
- I love that.
- I got credit
for playing nails.
(laughing)
I did.
- I love that.
I love it.
All right so.
Oh, thank you so much Justin.
Give it up for Justin.
(Claps)
(audience cheering)
Dolly is so special to me, y'all.
And she's special to the entire show.
And I apologize that you're
standing here for this
'cause it's probably awkward for you.
But I'm gonna embarrass
you just for a minute
or just float your boat.
So this isn't the first time
that I've sung nine to five on this stage.
In fact, that song was
my very first Kelly Yoki
on this show, for this whole show.
- Oh, I didn't know that!
- Yeah.
Season one.
It was our very first one.
- Well, I'm honored.
- Yeah.
And like you, you said you had real,
like workers in the video.
So did we.
We had real police women.
We had real fire women.
- Oh yeah, I see them there.
Oh, look at that.
- It was really cool.
And, and I'm so excited though
to just sing that with you
and also just to have you here.
We're super honored.
- Well, I have always said we
would do a great show together
and I think we're going to.
'Cause I just relate to you so much.
I just think you're so real and so fun.
And everybody just loves you.
- That's what I think about you!
- Well, then that's why
we're gonna have on the show.
(laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Well, we're blessed to have Dolly
for the whole hour, everybody.
She is a legend.
(audience cheering)
In music, in fashion.
She's got two musical collections out now.
One is called
the "Holly Dolly Christmas
Ultimate Deluxe Edition".
My God, you smell so good.
The other, I'm just taking it in.
The other is
"Diamonds and Rhinestones,
The Greatest Hits Collection"
Both are available wherever
you get your music,
you'll gotta get them.
But Dolly is a worldwide
inspiration for her work
as a humanitarian as well.
That's why she's even cooler.
She just didn't stop there with music.
Nope.
That's why
we're introducing a new theme,
that's brand new for our show.
And it celebrates the
people behind the art
that they create.
So it starts with Dolly and
it's called "More Than Music".
(gentle music)
♪ More than music. ♪
- Okay.
Oh and I got my own cup.
- You have your own cup.
- I just love this.
- I know.
Ooh, and I have this
and I've got so many things
over here I'm gonna talk about.
Well wait, I have to say congrats.
You were just inducted into
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
- I know!
(Kelly claps)
(audience cheering)
- I wanna see, can I see it?
- I know.
I brought this for the show.
This is my rock and roll
and I just wanna share this
with you until you get
your own and you will.
- Oh, I will not but I love you.
(laughs)
- Yes, you will.
You will!
- You are so.
I think you have to.
Well, it's funny, I was literally talking
to my producer this
morning and I was like,
we throw around the word icon a lot.
Like I feel like everybody's an icon now.
Like, you know, everybody's
like, oh she's an icon.
I'm like, no, you have to earn that
and you actually earned that.
And it's like you, that's
why I loved your response.
I loved your response 'cause
you were like, well, wait what?
Rock and roll?
Like I'm country music.
But you are rock and roll.
The fact that you're a pioneer for women,
you've opened the doors for so many of us
to be able to be
vulnerable as songwriters.
But I don't know, does it make,
does it weird you out
to be labeled an icon?
Does it?
- Well, I always think of myself more
as an eyesore than an icon.
(laughs)
- Well, I wish you.
- But actually, but you know,
I used to think when I was young
if I made it like I'd hoped I would.
- Yeah.
- How people would remember me
when I was older.
Now I'm older
and it's really nice to look
back and think that, you know
I might have done something
that's helped inspire.
- Oh my God.
So many thing.
- Some, you know, some other people.
And when I got into the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
when they talked about that,
I didn't realize that it was
more than just that to me.
I always thought about the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
being for people to spend
their life in rock music.
- Yeah.
- Like country music
and you don't see Led Zeppelin
in the country Music Hall of Fame.
- Yeah.
- You know, so I,
when they first said that, I thought,
well, you know, I don't
know that I belong there
and I didn't wanna take votes
from other people that
had spent their life.
And that's kinda how I felt.
- Which is so dolly.
- But I.
- Who says that!
- But still, I honestly thought that.
But then later I saw that it
was for people also that have,
you know, influenced other people.
And I did say I would accept
it gracefully and humbly
and I did and I was very honored.
- But you did something even cooler.
You actually wrote like
a rock and roll song.
- I did.
I wrote a song for the show
about my whole experience about that.
It's called, I've been,
it's called "Rockin' It"
'Cause I've been rocking it.
I grew up loving Elvis
and while Man Jerry Lee,
Chuck Barry, little Richard
they had a cast of spell on me
and Carl Perkins in them Blue Swag shoes
had no place on the farm.
But there's better
than them Brogans I was
wearing around the barn.
♪ So I've been rocking, rocking, rocking ♪
♪ since the day I was born. ♪
♪ I'll be rocking till the day I'm gone. ♪
♪ 'Cause I got rocking roll
down in my country soul. ♪
♪ And I'll be rocking it
till the cows come home. ♪
- I love that!
(laughs)
(audience cheering)
That's so perfect.
- So yeah.
I'll go ahead and I'll
talk about the whole thing.
How, you know, how they, you know,
they put me in the Hall of Fame.
So guess, it ain't no
shame, is there, you know.
But since I heard the big news,
I ain't never been the same.
Cause they done gone and put me
in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
It's a dangerous thing.
But I was honored and I'm proud.
- I love that.
And it's so cool though how you do,
you're so respectful of other artists
and all their hard work.
But at the same time you're like
'cause you're doing an album now.
Like a rock album.
- I'm doing a rock album now.
I'm calling in Rock Star.
Rock Star.
- I love it.
- Just for fun.
But I'm actually,
I'm doing a classic songs
and I'm using a lot of
the classic artists too
to sing on some of the songs with me so.
- Wow.
- So I'm looking forward to that.
So this gonna come out next year.
♪ Go, tell it, tell it. ♪
♪ Go tell it on the mountain. ♪
♪ Over the hills ♪
♪ and everywhere. ♪
♪ Go, tell it on the mountain ♪
♪ that Jesus Christ is born. ♪
♪ Oh go, tell it on the mountain. ♪
♪ Over the hills ♪
♪ And everywhere. ♪
- Welcome back everybody.
I'm the luckiest person on planet Earth
because I am hanging
out with Dolly Parton.
(audience cheering)
That was a look
at Dolly Parton's
"Mountain Magic Christmas".
It premieres today on NBC.
In this new movie
"Mountain Magic Christmas"
you're playing yourself.
I wanna ask if you're
able to have fun with it
'cause you are playing yourself.
But also I have to say
you and Willie sound so good together.
- Oh we did.
- You and Willie Nelson.
I was like, this is
what, if anybody wondered
what Mountain Magic was,
it was what just occurred.
It was like, it was so good.
- Yeah.
Willie was on the show.
And we did "Pretty Paper"
song he wrote years ago.
♪ Pretty paper, pretty ribbons of blue. ♪
And we just had the sweetest time.
I've known him since we were both young.
Yeah, in Nashville.
And so having Willie
always through my life
and I thought I can't do
this show without Willie.
So we did that wonderful
song that I'd also recorded
in that, in my Christmas album
of Holly Dolly Christmas.
But yeah, we had, you know, we
had Jimmy Fallon on the show.
- I know!
- Miley Cyrus.
- Yeah.
- We had Billy Ray also.
- And we had Zach Williams
that we did the.
So we had a lot of wonderful,
wonderful artists on the show.
- It's so fun with shows like that
'cause you get to be more free.
- And Jimmie Allen as well.
- Yeah.
- Allen and Fallon.
- Oh Jimmy Allen, yeah.
But you get to, I love Christmas albums
and doing anything Christmas.
'Cause I feel like it's open game
and you can have other
influences too, like.
- Yeah.
- You know,
you just have a different experience
and it's like a more open vibe.
People aren't expecting one thing.
It's Christmas so like everyone's welcome
- But this is a two hour,
they call it a movie.
But actually I was like
you said, playing myself.
But I thought it'd be a
great idea to show how,
what it takes to actually do a show.
So it's really the making of a show.
All the trouble you have,
all the fights you have
to have behind the scenes.
All the stuff you don't want.
- Yeah.
- And so getting
to play myself.
- Which is real.
- It is real.
- Yeah.
- And so we got, I got a
chance to do some comedy
and do, you know, some
things kinda acting.
- Yeah.
- But still it's real.
Stuff that really goes on.
When you was talking earlier,
when you said you know,
I always seem so nice all the time.
- I know.
I'm like,
do you ever have a just (bleep) day.
Like you know what I'm saying?
(Dolly laughs)
Like I just, nobody, I don't even think
I could say that on here.
Whatever.
They'll bleep it but I'm just like.
- They'll bleep you
out, this is your show.
- Yeah, yeah, I know.
But I'm just like, I
literally was talking to her
and I was like, do you
ever have a bad day?
Just people do not catch it?
Like, I'm like, 'cause everyone loves you.
- You're everybody has a bad day.
But it's like when you're
in business, you know that.
When you're trying to do
a show, put on a show.
And that's why we thought
it would be a clever idea
to let people see what really goes on.
'Cause you gotta cuss people out.
You're not gonna take this,
you're not gonna take that.
You know, you gotta do this.
- I wanna see feisty Dolly so badly.
(laughing)
- But you know what, I try to
always keep a good attitude.
- Yeah.
- You know,
I'm one of those people
though I've often said
I can tell you where to put it
if I don't like where you got it.
(laughing)
So that's just.
- That's just being helpful.
- Yeah.
That's all I heard.
(audience clapping)